hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled structure-based vaccine design
for covid19 and other respiratory
viruses this webinar is
part of the microbiology virtual week
virtual event
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them
into the ask a question box located
on the top right corner if you have any
trouble hearing
or seeing this presentation just click
on that
ask a question box and i apologize on
the far left
corner of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
i now present today's speaker dr barney
graham
deputy director of the vaccine research
center
and the chief of the viral pathogenesis
laboratory
at the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr graham
welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
good afternoon name is barney graham as
you heard
and i'm going to talk to you today about
the work we've done over the last 10
years or so
on a structure-based vaccine design for
respiratory virus diseases
i work at the vrc vaccine research
center at niad was
founded in 2000 um
specifically to work on an hiv vaccine
and even though we have not achieved
that
an effective hiv vaccine the
technologies that we've developed
to to make that effort have
resulted in a number of other projects
to
to address problems with unmet
needs like influenza ebola
including a number of emerging
infectious diseases
and this is made possible because we
have the privilege not only to have a
research building for basic research but
we have other components of the brc
like the process development group in
gaithersburg which is a little over 100
engineers another group
in frederick just north of bethesda
to work on gmp manufacturing
clinic in the nih clinical center and
another group
to do glp assays on our clinical samples
and that has allowed us to explore and
develop
a number of delivery approaches
including nucleic acids
and vectors and virus-like particles as
we did for chikungunya
proteins and nanoparticles which i'll
say a bit about
especially for rsv and the coronaviruses
i think you'll hear from dr masaro
kanakio on some of the nanoparticle
approaches we're taking for influenza
and a number of monoclonal antibodies
including the
nab-114 that effectively treated ebola
in eastern democratic republic of congo
so we've been able to send these
products around the world either for
research or
clinical clinical use and it's done by
this small group of investigators and
program heads
led by john muscola who's there in the
center
in the blue shirt
so i'm going to talk about not just
structure based design but
pandemic preparedness in general and
we've been thinking a lot about this
during this decade especially because of
the
problems we've had with the chikungunya
and then mers coronavirus and then ebola
and then zika etc and just
on and on and it's led us to um
consider what can we do to get more
ahead of this and be more proactive and
so the approaches including a platform
approach meaning platform manufacturing
that can allow you
to plug and play with vaccine antigens
into the consistent
manufacturing approach
or a priority pathogen approaches as wh
or sepi have taken to select the
top pathogens of concern
sepi for instance chose lhasa and mers
coronavirus
and nipa virus uh who had a list of
eight
but we have advocated for a more
comprehensive systematic approach
that we call a prototype pathogen
approach for
pandemic preparedness that would address
all 25 virus families known to affect
humans
and the project i'll tell you about
today is an example of that
we think it's possible because these new
technologies have transformed
vaccinology as we used to know it
about 12 years ago
largely because of structure based
vaccine design concepts that i'll
say more about but also because of
single cell
sorting it gives you the potential for
rapid human monoclonal antibody
identification
defining antibody lineages as new
molecular targets for vaccine studies
and
to evaluate immune responses at a single
cell level
in vaccine trials
it also has stimulated a whole new
science on
protein engineering of self-assembling
nanoparticles and these kinds of
technologies have given us
a new precision of antigen design and
[Music]
effective to achieve
effective functional responses and
the other technologies included
at the bottom have helped us to go
faster
and we think that combining a precision
with speed
is what's needed in for both pandemic
preparedness and
for pandemic response i'll be talking
more about
the nucleic acid approach for vaccine
delivery
in this talk so for
for me this started in 2010 when we
started a project to
understand the structure of the f
protein of
respiratory syncytial virus f is the
fusion protein it's a class 1 fusion
protein analogous to
the coronavirus spike and it has
a antigenic cited at its apex
this red area here that
turns out to be highly neutralization
sensitive and was discovered
during the solution of this pre-fusion
structure i say prefusion because this
protein rearranges to accomplish the
process of membrane fusion that allows
viral entry
and during that rearrangement this
pre-fusion molecule
is triggered to rearrange into this
anti-parallel six helix bundle
uh post-fusion molecule and you see the
this neutralization sensitive epitope
that the apex is lost in this
rearrangement process
so the neutralizing epitopes that were
previously known were all
on the post-fusion molecule and missed
many of the
very sensitive sites at the apex of the
pre-fusion
when this post-fusion molecule has been
used in prior clinical trials
it could only boost neutralizing
activity two to three-fold
which made advanced vaccine development
more difficult but if you stabilize the
pre-fusion conformation with a
c-terminal trimerization domain and
internal
sulfide and cavity-filling mutations you
can
then boost a single boost in healthy
adults and achieve up to 16
fold increase in neutralizing activity
as we published just last year
so solving the atomic structure revealed
this new target of vulnerability
and we now have clinical proof of
concept for structure-based design
and the importance of preserving these
neutralization-sensitive epitopes
on these pre-fusion molecules and
that confirmation a conformational
approach to vaccine antigen design we
think can be generalizable and we've
done that now
not just for pneumoviruses but for
paramyxoviruses
and now for coronaviruses
just as an example in paramyxoviruses
and
peter quang has done this uh now for
peri-influenza virus one through four
we've done it for nipah and measles and
mumps
uh fusion proteins and
in each case shown that the pre-fusion
stabilized conformation of these
molecules
is significantly uh dramatically more
immunogenic and
potent as a vaccine antigen in the
post-fusion form
so when mers coronavirus came up
in 2012 and 13 right at the time we were
solving the pre-fusion confirmation of
the rsvf we decided that
this kind of approach was needed for
coronavirus
we tried jason mcclellan who is now a
faculty member
at dartmouth worked on this by
crystallography
and was unsuccessful he engaged andrew
ward
for cryo-em to do mers or sars one
spike uh structure and even with crow em
we were unsuccessful
but then uh serendipitously we started a
project on
hku1 and a couple years later asked if
we could
try to solve that and if this spike was
inherently more stable and allowed the
cryo-em
solution to its structure as shown here
and when that structure became available
and we could see sidechains
jason mcclellan's group and ours started
a process of finding stabilized
mutations and
at this site at the top of the central
helix that's in purple
it if you put prolines there it prevents
the stacking onto the heptad repeat and
largely stabilizes the fusion protein
and it turns out that those two prolene
mutations between the heptad repeat 1
and the central helix
also stabilize uh mers and st sars spike
sufficiently to allow um
the prolines are there to to allow a
solution of their structures and and
preservation
uh in the pre-fusion conformation of
these
apical neutralizing neutralization
sensitive epitopes
importantly especially for gene-based uh
vaccine delivery
not only did it improve antigenicity but
compared to the wild-type levels of
expression
the stabilized mers spike had
up to 50-fold higher protein
level expression levels than wild type
and as i mentioned it allowed us to not
only solve the structures for
mers and cyrus spikes but also then
endemic
human chronoviruses both another
beta coronaviruses and alpha
coronaviruses of veterinary
coronaviruses and even
sars like bat derived coronavirus spike
proteins
so knowing uh thinking that we had a way
of
making a coronavirus spike we wanted to
have a way of rapidly manufacturing a
new
vaccine antigen if a new coronavirus
emerged as we
expected it would since we had already
had two events within the last 10 years
and so in 2016 after working
closely with the company moderna for
mrna
who makes mrna vaccines during the zika
outbreak
we made a collaboration agreement with
them
to do a demonstration project on
the prototype approach to pandemic
preparedness
using both a nepa virus f is a prototype
for paramyxoviruses
and mers coronavirus is a prototype for
coronaviruses
the mrna approach then uses a
lipid nanoparticle packaging system
to deliver the mrna that's then
translated
into your protein of choice depending on
your overall design that
can then elicit antibody responses or
even
cea t cell responses since it's made
intracellularly and the
nature of this rna and its
manufacturing process affects the way it
works so you've heard of there's a
number of different ways of making
delivering rna in this case the rna
is has modified nucleosides it's got a
one methyl
uridine that diminishes the
intracellular signaling that could go
through
the tlr-7 and 8
[Music]
and it also has the double-stranded rna
cleaned up during the manufacturing
process which
diminishes the innate signaling through
these other intracellular
sensors that would create a big
interferon response and so this rna
delivers
and translates a protein that would with
relatively little innate signaling
that allows the protein expression to to
go on
longer and so making
uh the mrna for the mirror spike we
found
that either 0.1 or one microgram
of the mrna given twice
at a zero three-week interval
was able to protect entirely against
uh infection of the lung
and reduce illness and you see in the
weight curves even at the
0.01 microgram dose which only reduced
virus titers by
a half log you got partial
protection against a disease with this
partial immunity
so proline mutations in spike can
stabilize it in its prefusion state
and we know that the pre-fusion spike
trimers are more immunogenic
we thought it could be as general
solution for beta coronaviruses
and we had shown that mrna delivery
was feasible
and as i mentioned it was likely that
we're
going to get more coronaviruses
this is there's many coronaviruses in
nature
it's a common virus in many
mammalian species shown here
and over the last several hundred years
we've had
four coronaviruses enter human
population and become endemic these top
four two alpha viruses and two
beta coronaviruses and now over these
last 20 years we've had a sars
outbreak in a murs outbreak in the
middle east
and now another sars coronavirus
ii outbreak and it's likely that we'll
have more
coming from these animal reservoirs
through an intermediate host and then
some of them
learn how to transmit uh between humans
so when this new uh problem was
reported near the beginning of january
and
and then around the 7th of january we
heard rumors that it may be a beta
chronovirus
sars like virus we became interested in
in planning and at the time we were
planning to take the nipa virus
mrna into the clinic as our
demonstration project
but when this happened uh the ceo of
moderna
stefan von cell agreed to switch this to
the coronavirus
and work on this new coronavirus that
was emerging
as our demonstration project for the
clinic
many people have pictured this virus uh
in this cartoon
version but recently there's been a
beautiful
electron microscopy scanning em image
published by camille air in the new
england journal
showing remarkable resolution and you
can then focus in on one of these
viruses and see that
it's only about 80 nanometers in
diameter including
the big spikes and there's only about 24
spikes per particle so i would encourage
people to go
look at this and get a more
representational uh
virus the important thing is
uh is the spike and and so when
uh the sequences were released on the
night of the 10th of january
and we found them on the saturday
morning the 11th
a number of steps were taken because
knowing the structure for us has been
the key
in developing antigen solutions for
vaccines and so
collaboration again with jason mcclellan
who's now at ut austin
our groups decided what types of
constructs to order
for making protein and for
making probes and for constructs to make
other
assays and so
uh once we had the spike structure uh
and we knew that it was in the right
conformation despite not having
antibodies for validation
it allowed us to make diagnostic assays
as we did with the cdc
it allowed us to make b cell probes to
pull out and isolate and identify new
human monoclonal antibodies as we did
with abcelera
and lily who now got that monoclonal
into
phase three clinical trials and to push
it into
vaccine development as we did with
moderna using mrna but as others have
done
using vectors or protein-based
approaches
so i'm going to show you some of the
pre-clinical data that supports the
advancement of this product into phase 3
studies
in mice we showed that either two doses
or one dose of the vaccine
followed by either four or up to 13 week
challenges was protective
and we did this in collaboration with
ralph barrick who
while we were testing immunogenicity was
developing a mouse adapted form of the
sars2 virus
and just by modifying two amino acids in
its receptor binding domain
uh he was able to make a virus that
easily infected mice
and so with two doses in a four
week challenge interval you could
see that good elisa activity was induced
the red
is in the one microgram dose and that
level of elisa binding activity
results in about a one to 1 000
level of id 50 for a
pseudo virus neutralization even at a
single dose
if you use either one again in the red
or
10 micrograms in the in the
purple but you can generate good levels
of neutralizing
activity uh in this case again up to
about a thousand
and that level of activity from the two
dose regimen
one microgram could protect lung and
upper airway from virus infection
and measured by platforming units and
even the one dose at one microgram or 10
micrograms of the seven-week challenge
interval
is able to prevent infection in the lung
in the 13-week challenge after two dose
you also saw protection in both
lung and nose and in this case also we
could show
the pathology show no evidence of
enhancement so one of the important
aspects of this development program is
to use subprotective doses
in this case the 0.1 only reduced
titers by two logs and the 0.01 by half
a log
to ask whether in sub-therapeutic
doses you generated any evidence of an
enhancement of disease rather than
partial immunity leading to partial
protection and so you see in the top
pathology boxes that pbs
group the control group had inflammatory
nodules that happened on day two acute
lung injury
and thickened alveolar septa and
interstitial infiltrates mostly from
neutrophils and
lymphocytes on day four and these
changes were largely absent
from the groups that had a breakthrough
infection
so partial immunity led to partial
protection we also asked about
a response in aged mice again a
0 3 regimen followed by
a blood draw and then a seven
week challenge and you see the
one and point one microgram dose groups
again
that induced a robust
antibody response and i that included
neutralizing activity
and even this other uh product which is
div
meaning double inactivated as sars it
was inactivated
uh both with formlin and heat
and it had and this was made for the
sarsko v1
virus and yet it still had some
cross-reactive neutralizing activity
in this system and you could show that
the one microgram
in the older mice again protected
against
weight loss in this case the virus has
not only been mouse adapted by mutation
but
serially passaged and now can be
virulent
in older mice
without any additional modification
and so in this case
the the mice were protected in the
in the both the lung and the nose
at the 1 microgram dose and partially
protected at 0.1
and at the 0.1 you got partial weight
loss but then recovery the
whole inactivated and pbs groups
had to be sacrificed this is a
immunostain showing viral antigen uh
in the top row is day two in in in the
second row is a day four sample
and this is a pbs control on the far
left
and the double inactivated hole
activated virus on the far right
and you see that the one microgram dose
level there's no virus at either day two
or four there's some virus at the point
one partially protected
animals that's largely cleared by day
four
and in both the uh pbs
and the whole inactivated negative and
positive control groups
you got a lot of virus replication and
that consolidated into foci by day four
this was associated and the double
inactivated hole-in-activated virus
groups are on the far right here and the
in the purple bars and
and so this is a multiplex cytokine
array
and we asked whether this
positive control for uh enhanced disease
uh would induce a th2 response and it
did
you see il four five nine thirteen and
eotex and even being induced in
animals post challenged with this kind
of priming
and yet there's no indication of th2
responses
from natural infection or from any of
the mrna
prime demise including the breakthrough
group at 0.1
same is true for inflammatory cytokines
in this case
some of the inflammatory cytokines also
came up in the pbs group
but they're all up and higher in this
primed animal that got whole inactivated
virus and alum
as an ineffective vaccine
he then asked in monkeys whether these
dose of either 10 or 100 micrograms of
mrna would be protective
and these are binding antibody data
showing after a single dose
or two doses that all animals responded
and if you looked at a domain specific
responses like rbd
or the n-terminal domain response that
you could show that at 10 or 100
micrograms you made robust
antibody responses and they were
at the upper end or even above
convalescent responses
found in humans with a varying degree of
illness including
some people with very severe disease so
these are
robust antibody responses that are
can be shown for both the rbd and
n-terminal domains
we also looked at functional antibody
responses this is an
ace ii binding inhibition assay in which
again
at either 10 or 100 you showed responses
at the upper tier or above human
convalescent responses
and even a live neutral virus
neutralization assay
showed responses well above what are
seen
in convalescent human serum
we looked at t cell responses again
because of the association of th2
responses with the
prior episodes of vaccine-enhanced
disease
back in the 1960s with rsv
a whole inactivated virus but also in
animal models of sars one
so we thought it was important to show
in the humans that
in the monkeys that
peptide stimulated pbmc showed a
th1 biased response and no th2
responses in the bottom two panels you
see
on the right that also in there was a
strong induction of il-21 which has been
associated with
p-follicular helper cells which are
important for
germinal center b cell activation
and amplification
this level of antibody response largely
prevented
subgenomic rna which is a measure of
replicating virus
in the bal or the lower airway in the
lung
compared to the control group on the
left the 10 microgram and 100 microgram
dose groups had very little
[Music]
sub genomic rna detectable
there's eight animals in each of these
groups
and even in the upper airway using
a nasal swab sub-genomic rna you could
show
most of the virus in the upper airway
where
replication was prevented
next i'll show you the phase one human
data
in this case there was a zero four week
interval and uh in the younger age
cohort
there was doses of 2500 and 250
micrograms given twice
that were evaluated some uh
cohorts in the 56 to 70 or greater than
71 year old
age range were also immunized with
some of these same dose levels
now uh in terms of reactorgenicity
solicited adverse events
um are shown here and
there's a lot of information here so
just uh
look overall in the first column which
shows you the responses after a single
injection
and the second column shows you the
responses after
two injections and you see there's more
response after the second dose
these three bars represent a
2 500 and 250 microgram dose levels and
the gray is a
grade one the blue is a grade two and
the
red is a grade three reaction almost all
the grade three reactions are in the 250
microgram dose group
so that dose group was not continued
beyond this
uh younger 18 to 55 year old age cohort
otherwise the 100 microgram and lower
dose levels were well tolerated with
only grade 1 and 2
reactions the
antibody responses were robust
similar to what was seen in non-human
primates and the 100 microgram
dose level it was just as immunogenic as
the 250 microgram which made it easy to
select this dose level as the one that
goes forward
into the phase three trial and so you
see uh either for the full length
trimeric spike
or on the right the receptor binding
domain specific
antibody responses that everyone
responded after
a first dose and everyone was boosted
after a second dose and the responses
are relatively well maintained
out to at least four weeks post-second
immunization
and they're all at or above the
convalescent sera panel
shown on the far right
the same was true for neutralizing
antibody that was measured both by
pseudovirus neutralization or by
classical
plaque reduction neutralization prnt
with live virus
and again uh the
activity was uh at or above in the upper
uh quartile of convalescent responses
uh in this case there was some
neutralizing activity seen after the
first dose but
all people responded 100 of responders
after the second dose and even in the
elderly cohort i'll show you just some
of this
unpublished data that indicates that
at 25 dose levels
uh 25 microgram dose levels in the
younger age uh 56 to 70 and the greater
than 71
on the three groups on the left
all responded in a similar
to a similar level and at the 100
microgram dose level
of the older two age cohorts
of 56 to 70 and greater than 71
if anything were at or above where
a younger adult cohort was
so responses were also robust in elderly
subjects
at the 25 microgram and 100 microgram
dose levels
again the t cells were done as a
looking for a safety signal and in this
case there was no th2 uh
response and the response was heavily
biased toward
th1 cytokine production
which is what we were looking for and
there were some but very little
cb8 t cell response detected in the
peripheral blood
so in summary both in mice and monkeys
and humans we have
immunogenicity data supporting this
approach
we have protection data in mice and
monkeys in both
upper and lower airway and we have
safety data
established in humans
that all supported advancing into this
phase 3 trial
and so this was all done in
very rapidly and so as i mentioned
we were waiting for the sequences to be
released on the 10th
and we got them on the 11th we ordered
the
reagents we needed to make protein for
solving the structures and making the
assays and
isolating new antibodies but we also
selected a sequence based on our initial
mers work
putting the 2p mutations uh
two prolines into the 986 987 amino acid
positions between the heptad repeat 1
and the central helix
uh because of that prior experience
because of our prior relationship
uh stefan bonsail was willing to at risk
make this decision to go forward with
manufacturing and allowing
a gmp product to be available by
41 days after sequence released and
within just a few more weeks
the phase one trial was able to start
within about 65 days of the
sequence release there's now a phase two
trial that started
in may and the phase three trial as i
mentioned
started july 27th
and even though this was rapid i want to
emphasize
that not many steps have been skipped if
any
in this process the things that have
been put at risk were
money and time and we had
non-clinical immunogenicity data before
starting
phase one we had protection data in two
animals before
starting phase two and we had safety
data
by limiting dose
of vaccine and breakthrough infection
and pathology and
immunology before state starting
phase three and now we're in the midst
of a phase three trial
that is more than two-thirds in rope
this is not the only product going
forward
there's mrna in these
in phase three both from moderna and
from the pfizer bio and tech
collaboration there's whole inactivated
virus vaccines
from china and recombinant ad vectors
from
uk and china and also coming along
quickly or recombinant subunit proteins
that are appear to be very immunogenic
and so
there's 34 vaccine candidates in
clinical evaluation and seven of them
have already reached phase three
trials and according to wh there's at
least another 142
vaccine candidates in pre-clinical embed
evaluation including things that use
nanoparticles chimeric viruses
additional vectors and virus-like
particles so
there are a lot of options here and it's
remarkable what's happened this last
year in terms of
the the promise of vaccine technologies
really
coming to the fore in this crisis
situation
so these are some of the products that
are uh advancing as i mentioned
moderna and um pfizer both have rnas
that are already
uh over two-thirds enrolled in
phase three trials astrazeneca just
recently started their phase three
novovax
and j and j will be starting soon
and so there's a lot of progress being
made and i just
put asterisks by these products because
five out of the first six
products at least in phase three in this
country are using the
two proline stabilizing mutation
as as what they considered a maybe a
better
vaccine antigen this is all being
organized under
a new system that was designated
operation warp speed but
it really is a way of uh more
of organizing and with all
due deliberation uh the multi-agency
effort
in the government combined with the
multi-company
effort from all the pharmaceutical
companies
and so this is
not only covering vaccines but
therapeutics and diagnostics
the vaccine group has both components of
vaccine development
supply and manufacturing and also a big
work on delivery and administration
and just to show you how the government
approached this problem the prior
systems including the hiv vaccine trials
network
hiv vaccine preventions network
and the old vtu and now the new idcrc
and even dod sites combined into a
consortium of government sites now
called coronavirus
prevention network that covers
much of the country is shown here in
these
red dots and when you combine that with
the
company's cro
sites that are contract sites you can
cover virtually
the entire country and in the case of
moderna there's 99
sites activated to enroll this trial
there's a website now for the network if
you're interested in finding
out more about it
coronaviruspreventionnetwork.org
and there's a big effort through
dod and others that
and uh hhs uh putting predictive
analytics and
really uh amazing modeling and
and computer power behind this to try to
anticipate
how the outbreak is moving by using
county maps of prevalence and new cases
and overlaying that with the testing
sites
and places like meat packing plate
companies who
have known to have uh major outbreaks
and and now colleges etc so
these kinds of approaches will help um
a shift uh emphasis on enrollment to try
to capture
cases in the phase 3 trial so i'll
summarize here
by just restating that
this is all made possible the rapid
development was made possible by prior
fundamental basic and translational
research
this idea of combining precision
vaccinology and platform manufacturing
for both
precision and speed
proactive planning toward
[Music]
virus families that may have a
proclivity for
pandemic threats and pre-established
public-private partnerships
which allowed this to go rapidly
and this mrna 1273
is well tolerated in mice monkeys and
humans
it's protective and mice and non-human
primates
it's immunogenic and older age groups
and as i mentioned the phase 3 trial now
is more than two-thirds enrolled and i
just want to thank the pis that i
introduced earlier that i work with
every day jason mcclellan who's
now a professor at ut austin is still an
important collaborator on many things
dr kizmikia corbett who's hiding here
uh has been the leader of our small
coronavirus
uh sub team and has
generated much of the data that you saw
on mers and
the early data now on this new virus
our collaborators at moderna ralph
barrick
and his group at unc who's done all the
mouse
challenge studies and and uh live virus
assays and
mark dennison at vanderbilt and jim
chapel who have done a lot of the pr t
work and i've been
both long-term collaborators so i will
stop there and take any questions if you
have
thank you dr graham for that informative
presentation and we will now start the q
a portion of this webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask if this is the time
please do so now by clicking on that ask
a question box located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have a couple questions
coming in and we hope to get some more
dr graham
our first question is at what stage of
enrollment
is the phase three study
yeah so uh we are uh
around 21 or 22 000 in the moderna trial
and i
think the pfizer trial which is using an
mrna and a
stabilized spike pre-fusion trimer
uh similar very similar products to the
moderna they're up well over 23 or 24
000. so these trials which have a target
enrollment of 30
000 are should be there within the next
few weeks
thank you so much and our next question
there's been a lot of concern about
the vaccine safety what steps have you
taken to ensure that the vaccine is safe
many people just are inherently
distrustful of vaccines and because of
this
going so fast and people not really
understanding why it was able to go so
fast there
has been a lot of concern about maybe
it's going too fast and it's not safe
but
i hope that i explain to you some of the
basic
biology and scientific underpinnings of
why it was able to go faster this time
than it has ever gone before
some of the pre-established
relationships and
information we had and uh
and that we have generated a lot of data
both in animal models
and in humans and have gone through all
the typical phases but it's just all
done
in parallel and at the same time a lot
of
risk is being taken on advanced
manufacturing and
process development for these different
products that typically
would be done serially instead of in
parallel so a lot of money
has been put at risk but i hope i've
been able to
convince you that none of the essential
steps in
safety have been skipped and in fact
in some ways they've been scrutinized
even more heavily
because of this speed than we
often do thank you so much
dr graham we have time for one more
question i want to give you some closing
remarks time as well
when will you know the answer from the
phase three study
these are endpoint driven trials so
the second doses in at least the moderna
trial started
a few weeks ago and so 14 days after
that second dose was
september 7th so we've only been
counting new
cases symptomatic cases that are pcr
confirmed
starting from the 7th of september and
the first interim analysis will be when
we get up to 53 cases
the next analysis we think that could
give an answer would be at 151 cases so
it really is a matter of
infection rates and where enrollment has
happened and who gets infected and who
isn't
and potentially how effective the
vaccine is if it's highly effective
versus modestly effective it would
affect the timing
so that's going to be an experimental
question
dr graham this has been a great
presentation thank you so much would you
like to provide the audience
with some closing remarks before we end
our presentation today
well i think the most important thing to
that i think this work represents is the
importance of basic research
in being prepared for future problems
because it was really
knowing the structure and knowing how to
stabilize
structures that at least allowed our
group to
get off to a fast start and
so the importance of basic research just
being
underneath all of the activities that
have happened
the prior planning and prior
relationships i think are critical
and the idea that we could potentially
with some relatively minor investment
which seems minor especially considering
all the trillions of dollars that are
being lost out of our economy now
that could be invested in proactively uh
studying and preparing for potential
pandemics out of
the other virus 25 virus families that
we know
can infect humans and the
the efforts that would be spent on
solving structures and making antibodies
and developing animal models and things
like this i think
would put us in a much better position
in the future for unexpected
outbreaks
dr graham thank you again for your
presentation today before we go i want
to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions and any questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted
during our on-demand period will be
addressed via the speaker
of the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for
six months until march 2021
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's
live event until next time be safe
stay healthy and take care bye